you're not a regular mom you're a cool
you're honestly the coolest mom
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone do we just become best friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters i know you
love us i know you want us here we are
baby sistine and sophia stallone
i'm sorry
i think i outshined you with this intro
i don't really think so i think it was a
little a little fast
i think there was a lot of variety i
think it was pretty monotone i feel like
my voice fluctuated so much you know why
it didn't fluctuate
because you look like you're in dexter's
laboratory miss scientist this jacket is
very
listen
today were you just in the labs like
finding a new discovery on a disease or
are you oh you're here trying to figure
out the cure to koben you know what
sofia don't hate me because you ate me
i thought our guest is quite important
today so i'm gonna look a little bit
sophisticated and actually look like a
veterinarian so i'm not sure and guess
what she said she doesn't like to date
veterinarians oh times have changed oh
wow the tables have turned how is
everyone doing how did you sleep last
night
like a rock yeah you know what
the couple last couple days i was
sleeping horribly but now i've been
actually eating three of your melatonin
gummies and that's been knocking me out
dude if you're going to steal them from
my room just take the jar at this point
do you not eat them
you do oh yeah yeah i like a little
mouse in there i don't tell her i sneak
i know because i think i think i don't
notice the jar going down every day well
i don't know if you don't eat them or
not and so i don't want to tell you that
i eat them every night i don't know
what's worse stealing and lying about it
or just
i just told you
well i uh you know my melatonin
addiction i was drinking it at 7 30 last
night 7 30. i actually asked her i said
are you a sicko like why are you going
to bed not sick oh that's a little
aggressive
am i a sicko
[Applause]
you guys better be watching this on
youtube i'm giving you a root canal
after that actually you do look this is
a good role play
of mothers watch this show
ah mothers take note
sophia okay i'm getting back her head's
a little kinky right now because we
started watching the magic mic
excuse me listen we were watching
there's a magic mike reality show where
they literally get random guys off the
street and audition them to be the next
magic mistake it's so funny you guys it
is
so insane
the these guys doing body rolls and they
have no dance experience it's so hard to
walk well it's polar opposite guys it's
they're all not the same at all like one
is they're all like either skinny or
bigger or shorter or taller like every
thing in between and it's just to point
out that you don't need to be like the
magic might you don't need channing
tatum to be a mouse
honestly
you kind of need to be changed yeah the
whole message behind it is like
you don't need to have all of these
traits to find your magic
but i'm sorry
yay mike yeah yeah like
chad tatum does it no you got no magic
and you ain't mike speaking of which
they're having another magic mic movie
called the final dance
gabby you're excited the last it's
tonight
i've had a lot of sleep so i have a lot
of energy right now it's sponsored to
you by melatonin gummies from sistine's
room
i don't know what to say sophia let's
just talk about um
weddings
oh yeah oh go into the chapel and
why do you always try to harmonize just
sing it with me
you always harmonize but do you remember
that yeah late at night with
sustainability before coming back from a
bar or an event yeah okay that's right
so after coming back from a bar event we
bought a couple of ship glasses of
champagne by ourselves we just look at
each other we start singing but try to
harmonize i remember we tried over and
over what was the song
was it an ariana grande song
i think so it was so
i think it was like oh break up it's
your boyfriend because i'm bored now
we're getting off topic but yeah so um
the reason why sustained brought up
wedding invites is because i just got
one in the mail
and i knew about this wedding coming up
but now i just got to save the date
and i'm just looking at the card front
and back i know the girl and i the
wedding is gonna be beautiful i'm really
excited for her but um this is the
second wedding i've been getting invited
to also i've heard that's not that much
i'm only twenty-five but i know cousin
has yeah as long as i'm saying i know
he's about six years so many and one
it's just kind of surreal to see some
that's your age getting married like you
know the whole thing but did you think
that would be you
um um
no
no no
no no no no no you know me well how do
you feel that your ex is gonna be at
that
wedding ah sistina this should not be
included the doctor is we're gonna
naughty we're gonna see
okay
i'm not even oh you talked about your ex
in your snapchat we can't talk about
that you're gonna see him at a wedding
what's the difference i can't talk about
this why
because it's wrong
you've already talked about him okay
this is tina i'm going to this solo so
yeah he might i don't i'm since i'm not
dating anyone i'm single
yeah he'll probably be there but what do
you think about being single at a
wedding do you think that's better or do
you think it's better to bring a plus
one because i actually was thinking
about that and i don't look i don't have
a plus one but so i got no choice well
unless you
well it depends on what you're going for
because i feel like there's this whole
preconceived notion of if you're going
to a wedding single you're going to hook
up with
you know best man or something
oh and if you're not looking to do that
then yeah bring a plus one
well i mean look i just going to the
wedding to hook up yeah but i just see
it in all the movies you know wedding
crashers it's like so i find love at the
wedding
you know as your sister i want to be
honest with you and i'm going to say no
to answer no
but you never know
love could come a knock in
any time hello who's there i feel like a
therapist right now in this game
i am like the guy from split
who has 39 different personalities oh
wait look at dr
doofenshmirtz from vinnie is a verb
that's what it was like
and joe's so lack okay wait actually
then i have a doctor i have a question
do i look like sandy from spongebob
sandy is uh
oh wait maybe more doctor do for sure
but what is this thing it's like duper
spread
incorporated
what would make the wedding cringy when
i was in eighth grade my dance teacher
got married and she made it circus theme
so she went to a zoo and got married i
didn't go but this is what she do yeah
and then so on the table for snacks she
had a
um
bowl of carrots and a bowl of
uh ranch dipping sauce and i was like
that's pretty it was pretty great the
wedding
yeah okay
the wedding was at his zoo well it was
like a bowl of carrots
what
i asked what
would make a wedding cringey
what do you mean i know but i'm do i
look like a bowl of rice
okay you answer it
okay
okay
this is maybe not popular opinion but i
think the dances that the grooms or the
bride does for like the groom or bride
sits in the chair and they have like a
whole dance routine i'll tell you what's
crazy that makes it i don't it's sweet
but like a little cringy when the i hope
she's not when the bridesmaids and the
groomsmen do a little dance when they're
walking down the aisle well you have to
stop
so you have to do stop
stop the doctor says stop i don't want
to see leapfrog before i get married
okay i don't want to see the choctaw
slide before i say i do
i don't even see the hold down throw
down before i say i do but i think
that's not bad you're supposed to do
that right it's so
dorky
so
okay
well you want us to put on like ymca and
we're coming down like
it's so dumb
it's so dumb oh god is there something
that you would for sure need to have at
your wedding then
for sure need to yeah well you're
canceling the dance today so no one can
dance for sure
for sure what i need to have at my
wedding um
is a groom for sure for of course of
course that's a good idea that's pretty
important
and
um
an ordained minister
i don't really want a big wedding
everyone's like you need a big wedding
no one's telling you to get a big
wedding
i didn't say that at all
i think a big a big wedding's fine if
you're
younger i mean actually i don't know i
don't think i have enough friends to
invite like that many people that's true
you don't i'm just kidding you're more
than bad no if i got my life if you got
my marriage like if i got my marriage
license would you like no no
if you look like this
no
if this is the outfit you're gonna wear
on this watch you wear the same exact
suit to our dancing i honestly thought i
looked i was going for haley bieber
vibes today you're shaking your head now
i'm getting one yes and one now no no
you really all right you know what
this is for all the people listening
when people try to knock you down
for your choices for your alpha choice
you know why she's triggered because
she's good at getting herself ready and
now she actually had a bad
wardrobe day let me tell you my point
when people try to knock you down for
doing something that makes you feel good
put a middle finger in the air baby do
you they're just jealous yeah my mom got
me this jacket so stuck on my toe
i literally did not want to interrupt
you because i wanted to see how far she
would go with that is the dumbest thing
i've ever heard and um i feel really
well in doubt shout out i feel really
bad for we have a very very cool guest
coming on today and this is a very not
cool intro
and she doesn't look cool at all either
if you want
i don't think you are at all i'm
carrying the team today
i i'm pretty sure i made everyone in the
room laugh about 28 times i mean people
have today
exactly they're laughing because it's
false yours i even told her this in the
car she's so mean to me on the show do
you guys agree with this every time she
shits on me and i try to [ __ ] on her one
time she gets triggered
look at her
exactly she's triggered one time her
outfit is shitty and she makes fun of me
for wearing a hoodie a lot first of all
look at her it's styled so it's not
shitty stoud yeah
second of all
we roast each other the same sister
i just not really i think i'm just
better at it
i am
yeah because i'm a nicer human being
whatever you want to say chica that's
obvious or you who insulted me in the
car today you i insult you you apologize
to me yesterday for yelling at me who
was nice today me
me me
let's introduce our guest
this is the worst century and if you
actually want to just get to the good
part of the interview just fast forward
first 15 minutes and uh this was just
more a dialogue between christina going
through whatever it's true computer
screen black all right we have no idea
today
is a guest
that i am so excited about because i
don't think we've had a guest even
remotely similar to her at all no
career-wise
completely different i mean it's really
you know what it's cool is that so just
so we can tell everyone who it is it's
heidi dimilio and i think why we're
really excited about this is there's so
many questions we have that we haven't
been able to ask anybody else about fame
and social media the quick rise to it
i'm just so excited to finally
talk to someone that is living
this insane
tick-tock wild life and to get an honest
answer she's a mom she's raising two
daughters that have blown up massively
on tick-tock some of the biggest
creators on the platform
and her life is completely done at 360.
so i really cannot wait to get into her
brain so stay tuned for heidi dimiglio
[Music]
doing this podcast every single week
with my sister is always fun we love to
discuss whether it's dating health
wellness
mental health or breakdowns everything
in between so we are excited to bring
something new to the show that will
hopefully teach you guys something about
saving we are calling this new segment
unfiltered finance brought to you by
moneyline moneyline is a financial app
of innovative products that are designed
to help you own your money life download
it today in the app store it combines
motivation knowledge products and offers
into a personalized app experience that
helps you own your money life every
single day all right i'm just gonna say
wtf is inflation so let's just talk
about it the basic definition of
inflation is the increase of prices of
goods and services over time
so sophia
how does that affect us how because of
inflation the value of a dollar lowers
each year for example a hundred dollars
five years from now cannot buy the same
amount of stuff it can buy today right
so it means that the return you get from
any investment is at least more than the
inflation rate otherwise your money
would actually lose its value over time
interesting okay so knowing that
what is going on today well okay so the
most recent cpi report shows that prices
rose over time across the board in
december overall prices climbed seven
percent year over year the largest
increase since june of 1982.
have you noticed this times you've been
to the grocery store or when you started
your holiday shopping or whatever it is
that you may have noticed that the
consumer prices have spiked yes it's
wild my nails cost 15 more dollars now
than they did a year ago i mean it
really does add up it feels like it's
worse now than ever before and that's
just in la so it's probably even worse
in new york where everything is so much
more expensive let's play a little game
okay
how much do you think rent has increased
in new york over the last year
um
probably i mean
not that i look at a lot of apartments
but i'd say like 10
10 okay how about that's not even a
close guess sophia no it's
22.8 meaning if someone was paying
fifteen hundred dollars for a studio
last year that same apartment would cost
around one thousand eight hundred and
forty two dollars today it is and most
employees are still only getting three
percent adjustment to their salary each
year if that but inflation is moving
much quicker and it feels like we
actually can't keep up anymore so you're
probably asking
what do we do
because small businesses have to
increase their prices due to the supply
and demand and i still want to support
the local coffee shops okay well i think
the only thing we really can do is take
a hard look at what we're currently
spending the money on and see where we
can cut back so that we can still
support those local businesses that we
love
my shopping addiction is going to take a
hit
you know what i think for everybody in
this room will agree it's probably for
the best boo
[Music]
you might know her as the mother of two
of the today's biggest internet
celebrities dixie and charlie but this
boss woman has her own incredible
following with over 2.4 million
instagram followers where she shares her
passion for health and wellness home
decor and fashion and business and we
are just so so so so excited to have on
the beautiful heidi damilia
studio audience
we were just saying to her that we saw
that when you were following us and the
fact that we got this whole thing to
happen we were freaking out before we
saw that you followed us we lost it
we're like there's no way she like would
know who you are who you are
but do you know who you are i know
but like you guys have been
in a famous family your entire lives
like this is very new so to me i'm
looking at you guys oh my god
i feel like you know we're in the same
position honestly we're like slowly
but it's interesting because we're not
on people's timelines and news feeds 24
7 and i feel like i've seen you so much
and your family on the internet that i
almost know you guys personally at this
point so that's where it's different so
right sofia said we were just so
excited to have you on and just
understand
you know your journey before internet
fame and now and i mean i have so many
questions
we were saying in the intro like you are
probably our most unique guest because
there's so many things that we have
questions about that we have no idea
that you would only be able to say and
like get to experience because it's so
different than anything i mean like you
guys
were i don't know how was this started
like where were you living before and
how was it life before this entire thing
changed so i'm from louisiana and when i
was
25 i just i moved on my birthday to new
york city
and then i met mark like later that year
and then uh he was born in new york city
and uh
like
ended up growing up in connecticut so
after we got married um
rent was really high
it was like at the height of the market
so we're like and i wanted to have kids
i'm like i can't do it in new york city
like it's i need a yard and did you guys
want kids right away after you got
married we were kind of just chilling
and then like my sisters had trouble
getting pregnant and so my sister called
mark and she was like just so you know
the o'brien girls you know sometimes
take a long time to get pregnant and so
don't wait
forever so we're like oh my god and i
got pregnant right away i was like oh
there we go how did you know that mark
was the one
i
knew instantly really yes okay so how
old was i i was
25
and
he and i had both just kind of recently
gotten out of really long relationships
that weren't bad they were just like
yeah so um it was if they would have had
like hot girl summer that would have
been me
that wasn't a thing at the time but i
was like you know what single me i'm
gonna live in new york city yeah do my
thing and right
and we met and i was like well i'm done
he was when you know right wait this is
a funny story yeah i don't know if this
is out there but
he was um
had a lot of um he was i guess play in
the field or whatever so after our first
date
he uh
put some packages of together of things
that some girls had left at his
apartment stop it and
overnighted them and then like it was
nice to know you like i've met someone
like right after really and they knew as
well yeah and he called his so he and
his sister are super super tight and she
was with her best friend who's like
family and he called them and he was
like dude i'm that girl i'm gonna marry
and they're like get them wait wait wait
there's
yeah hold on what was your first date
and you said you knew after the first so
i worked at a gym i was a personal
trainer
and the guy that ran my gym
when he and mark were in college they
were roommates so mark moves into new
york i moved new york city january he
moves in in july and he's like oh i'll
give you a gym membership come right and
so he keeps trying to
like get us to go out he's like mark's
like i'm not going in the gym and asking
her out right like no okay and then um
i was and so he and then the same guy is
telling me all these stories about mark
in college i'm like he sounds like a dog
like oh my god
i'm boxing up that stuff like okay
martial is he post college like
um but he was like trying to sell
him to me and me to him and
i was modeling at the time so he had my
comp card and he they would go out to
dinner and he'd bring my comp card
that's so cute
are you saying yeah yeah that's so cute
i ran my gym
somewhere it's like so chill it was a
world gym and they had one party a year
it was bash christmas party yeah all of
a sudden we're having a party i'm like
oh wait i thought we only had christmas
parties they're like oh yeah we're
switching it up this year i'm not
pushing i'm like yeah yeah
in new york city like free food free
drinks let's do it so i go
there's mark you know we uh hit it off
and but i had a plan with my two
roommates
um she worked at this bar
at this club and then my other roommate
was going on a date so we were all gonna
like meet up go and let's all go to her
place her bar because she was dating the
manager and we could get free drinks
i love honestly
i so respect the hustle i mean you gotta
go
no i'm still trying to figure that out
so although i was modeling i wasn't
making a lot of money but anyway so i
we i show up and the line is at the door
there's like a lot of like bachelorette
parties there yes at this particular
place so
the line's out the door but my roommate
stay in the manager so he's like okay
[Applause]
i walk in i go to the back to meet her i
turn around mark's there
how did you get in here stop how did you
do that there was a line out the door
uh-oh and he was like i just want to see
you i was like
that's so cute i love that it was
i was like blown away like
first of all to make the effort and like
it was just so sweet well if he wanted
to he would exactly and he did
apparently so
we danced all night
and it's like a movie that was on i
think that was on a
saturday night and he was like
let me take you out on a date on
thursday night
and i said i have a client like a
standing client 5 30 a.m every friday
monday wednesday friday i'm like there's
no way
i'm gonna make it on a friday morning
yeah i i can't but another night like i
would love to and he was like all right
that's cool and i had uh so
after like he dropped me off at my
apartment and that was it and i had
instant regret and i'm like okay so we
have no cell phone and i don't know i
don't even know how to spell his last
name because i contacted him so i'm in
the yellow pages but i don't know
the yellow pages the white pages i knew
he had just moved to new york city so he
probably wasn't listed so i'm like
calling like the operator like i need a
listing for mark miller i his name is
spelled with a c i didn't know i didn't
know how to spell his last name i
finally got it and i called
and he didn't answer it was like a
voicemail and i called like 10 times
stop hoping you pick up like throughout
the day
i know i didn't know caller id i didn't
know like that was a thing
no no and so he saw that i was saying
ten times
an emergency calls back he was like hey
what's up and i was like
crazy enough my client cancelled friday
morning totally didn't i canceled on him
and i was like so thursday night still
it was good wait so thank god you
cancelled thank god thank you
and so we went out uh to this cool like
loungey bar place and um
i just never met anyone like him first
of all yeah he's he's to this day the
funniest person i've ever met humor is
important i honestly
so i thought that was hilarious and he
was just like
um like he like what are you what are
you gonna wear tonight like
what guy asked that but it's cool it's
like different i like when guys change
it up and i we always say this it's like
i think it's the comfortability yeah
it's like you know he immediately felt
comfortable enough to be like what are
you doing tonight and very like
confident
he also talked about you know earlier we
were talking about sisters and like he
has a sister who's like his best friend
that's the key that is the key honestly
and he and his mom and his sister are
super tight so the relationship that he
has with his mom
i'm like ready set go flag that is so
good yes
you know what that is like a mo why
don't guys court women like that today i
know the way that it was really funny as
you're saying you flipped through the
white pages it's like sophia and i's
version of going on their linkedin
profile today
which is
and then i'm like oh my god this is it
this is it like i didn't think about
anything else but like this did you this
is going to be the rest of my life i
feel like sometimes it's so exciting
it's exciting were you nervous was it
like exciting but nervous
i knew this was it yeah and how did you
know he felt the same ways but not
nervous
i never thought that he didn't also
i don't know i like that mentality he
gave me nothing that made me think
anything any different than that sophia
you should listen to that advice when
they give you a nightmare
on a tuesday and then we end up going on
a date on thursday so when you say i'm
giving you nothing to worry about
yeah
but he said this is almost a deal
breaker in this date in this first day
we're vibing we're having a good time
we're having cocktails and he says he
was allergic to dogs and i'm like
that actually is a joke
this is it
for a big dog
like i can't do this yeah how do you not
have a dog as much as like i think i
love you but i need a girl
he was like i'll get allergy shots i was
like that's love which he did put her
right on it and he does it do you have
dogs now we have a lot of dogs oh yeah
we're a big dog family my mom has four
dogs if that doesn't scream commitment i
don't know what does so you're in new
york with mark and then you guys end up
getting married and moving where so we
moved to connecticut okay and uh so kind
of starting your life over his mom and
sister were there which is amazing his
sister's my best friend so
that was awesome and then i got pregnant
with dixie right away and it was
crazy he had just started his business
so
um
it was just like a very intense time
with like a newborn and my family was
all in louisiana but like my dad my mom
and dad came up when i had her and they
stayed a couple weeks right that whole
thing so i don't know we just i'm very
much just like okay i have a newborn and
this is what i'm doing you know i had
made the decision together that i wanted
to be home so um and he was running his
business so i just um did that i was
very like tunnel vision like okay just
got it no it's good you're alive yeah
you're helping me
thank you check it out at the same time
like mark and i kind of had this thing
where we were like this is our world
that she's going to come into we're not
going to change who we are yeah for now
this newborn who's kind of like a potted
plant like right right you know so we
still like dated like we would but our
kids always came with us we would bring
them uh trips and dinners and yeah so i
didn't really i didn't really know
anybody there so i didn't have a
babysitter and she was little so i'm
gonna take them all over that's so cute
my mom took us out everywhere too wasn't
like daddy but that's that's like the
best way to raise your kids yeah because
they need that constant attention and
love and then seeing you and your
husband be so loving with each other is
so important for a child i'd like to
think they have a good example you know
oh definitely and then fast forward like
life happens and
next thing they're teenagers and you're
like oh my god yeah we wanted to so when
did charlie come into play because like
first he had dixie did you know you
wanted a second so when i had dixie i
knew i wanted right like
oh yeah no just sign me up for girls for
sure i ended up having two miscarriages
and then i said you know what i had felt
like i had been pregnant for so long
because i had one and then another one
and then right i was like
let's just like enjoy ourselves right
we're not going to worry about and then
i got pregnant i was like
do you think that was the key that you
were just getting out of your mind
honestly maybe it was the stress maybe
it was just like the mentality of it and
you were just putting so much pressure
on yourself to get pregnant and all of a
sudden you're like you know what i'm
just gonna put in someone else's hand
like everything
like anything you want and you're
seriously focused on you're if you're
like committed to it and do the work
like it's probably going to work out
yeah
not with that no no you're like you know
i am doing this i'm taking all the
vitamins and doing all the things and i
was like so the second we were like you
know what let's just live and if it's
meant to be it'll happen and well it
happened so she thinks she was an
accident i'm like trust me we were
trained
oh my gosh that's just so it's just your
phone i swear
yeah i know they always have those
assumptions but you guys seem like a
very very close family has it always
been the dynamic growing up like were
you that mom that was because my mom it
was family dinner
she was a helicopter and sly was sort of
the comedian of the yeah
i think mark would probably i don't know
if he'd say helicopter but he'd say you
coddle them too much oh my god
she would still spoon feed us if she
could yeah [ __ ] honestly but like it was
a weird i don't know i was we we we had
our things we were strict about yeah
they were different things like i was
strict with like the schedule
and going to bed and getting your
homework done right i just by a certain
time yeah mark was like and they'll
sleep when they're tired like that's so
sad but the things he was strict on i'm
like that's so dumb like that doesn't
even matter yeah
exactly
but my mom says that she could never
raise
all of us the same because we were so
different yeah how did you raise dixie
differently than you raised charlie you
know i struggled with that because they
are very different dixie was very like
you know
more
if she wanted to like create this whole
big thing i'm like
can we
just
like get back to that tomorrow and she's
like all right charlie will tell you
like
this is why we need to do this right now
and like a whole
distribution
like she will go back and forth and
dixie's not like that right and so it
was hard for me because i was more
used to
like okay well this is what i told you
to do so just do it because you do it
and charlie was like
no i got it like really how we're gonna
do it but mark is that way like he likes
the going back and forth and so
they got they were she was she was like
they were together all the time okay and
then she went through a thing where she
called me heidi and i was like oh
excuse me i know when my mom doesn't
answer us we go jan and chase oh i call
it
it's weird i call my dad fly and he's
always like even today people are still
like why do you call your dad sly we're
like i don't know it's just not
funny yeah so that was kind of like
so they were like inseparable and dixie
and i we probably have more of a similar
personality so um right we're just more
quiet and
chill and they were
just doing a million things but it's
changed like yeah
like we're all there's certain times
where like charlie and i are better
together or like she comes to me for
certain things on to mark and then dixie
will go like it just runs
the best part about having a big family
because if i'm pissed off at sofia i'll
call my mom about it but i know sophia
just called my mom about it but she'll
take both of our sides it's like perfect
we all talk [ __ ] interesting as we get
older our relationship with our moms are
totally different now it's like more of
a friendship and so we'll go to our mom
for things yeah well if it's dating or
whatever it is but i think almost a
relationship it's always been great but
it's almost it's for me i like it better
because it's more like independence but
we still also have that like bond that
we can always go to for anything yeah
yeah i heard this advice and it was
probably one of the best pieces of
advice i've gotten as a mom of kids that
are getting older was especially for
dixie when she moved out as uh the
advice was you have to look at it now as
you're more like taking a consultant
role like you're not gonna go to her
house and tell her oh you need to wash
your dishes and make your bed like no
you she's paying her all her own bills
like i don't know right you know she's
doing her own thing so
you don't really have that
i can tell her you know you function
better when you're what was that when
your apartment is clean yeah was that
hard for you to sort of
you know let go yeah just like zip it
because it would it was annoying to her
and when i kind of got that in check i
feel like our relationship changed
and she now she's she knows when i go
over i'm not going to do that now
right so now when i go over she's like
do you want to play organizing for me
and i was like oh my gosh so that is
exactly like
i did it like without her saying that
like
totally would have been different that's
something that we're dealing with
currently right now my parents have a
really hard time of letting go and
sometimes i have to remember that
parents have feelings and emotions too
and i think sometimes kids just think
that they're there to tell you what to
do but like they're also hurting they're
letting go of literally a piece of them
yeah and so understanding how to
compromise i think it's been like my
mom's now come to the conclusion she's
like actually now she goes no she says i
raised you from like babies to now and
this is the time you're more like the
most fun yeah with you like let me be a
part of that
peace out i think so
now that dixie has moved out
does charlie still live at home yes okay
so
you're raising full-blown teenagers
right now not just average teenagers
you're raising
internet phenom
if you don't know these girls you're
living under a rock i mean i couldn't
even imagine
the jump and like the cultural shock
that you must have gone through because
like she they joined the app originally
and you were still living in connecticut
yes okay did you guys did you know that
they were on the app originally yeah so
well we're pretty like we're pretty
savvy and yeah we always kind of
well for business mark was always on
social media yeah kind of thing but we
kind of there were parents that we knew
um that were
oh i'm not i don't want any part of that
and i'm thinking why
yeah just to know just to open the
the
space to have a conversation what if
it's something cool and fun they want to
share with you and you're like i don't
know what you're talking about like it's
shut down yeah so we i
we were kind of always a part i mean
there were things that i was like yeah i
don't like kids remember that one oh
okay guys i was like i have not read
that so long that one i never like yeah
yeah
anyways but like all these things but we
knew about enough about it to at least
give them guidance on like why this
could really take a bad turn like
whatever so we were we knew of it and
talking you know charlie would talk
about tick tock and i was like okay wait
what is it now right it was very
different and but i knew vine and i was
like well i guess she was like it's
harmless you're way more well versed in
this than our parents are our parents i
don't even think they really know what
tick-tock is
they don't even know how to tag people
on instagram yeah and it's very
confusing yeah she didn't have an
account but she was making videos with
like her friends at school but it was
dance she was a dancer and they're like
uh learn this dance and then teach it to
us cause it's just easier it's hard when
you're yeah
she's like okay so they would do that
and then like she had and then she ended
up starting her own like writing her own
account yeah and then she had one that
went viral it got like
10 000 views and she was like oh my god
the first time you hit like a cool viral
video wait a minute i know that it's
gonna work like you never know yeah you
honestly never know and meanwhile
dixie's cringing the whole time shoot
because at the time when tick tock first
started like
nobody wanted to admit they were on it
yeah that's what everybody was she
started
i did the same thing it was almost
embarrassing to be on tick tock but we
all secretly had private accounts
because i wanted to see what everyone
was doing she was making a bunch of
videos and i thought it was so
embarrassing why are you doing that it's
so weird and then also i'm like okay
she had had this one that went viral and
then everyone after that
how did you see the transition because i
i mean sometimes still today we get
shocked with like even our podcast for
example it growing a bit more and then
we see people coming up to us and going
like oh hey like we know who you are
we're like i don't know why um you
listen to the podcast did you guys have
some sort of moment where when you were
living in your hometown all that stuff
that things were starting to change like
this was becoming a lot more bigger than
you thought it was ever going to be
dixie's like yeah if you ever hit a
million i'll get on the app
like whatever oh dicks
she had a million and dixie was like oh
okay she didn't even have an account or
like she had one but it wasn't her name
yeah that was that's what i did so
charlie had planned this video and they
were wearing the same thing they they
looked exactly alike yeah it was like it
was this one trend where like the one
person standing there and charlie like
did like dixie did this to charlie and
she does this and thinks he's there but
they looked exactly like and the
internet went nuts and so
um
people were trying to find her and she
didn't have like a real profile and so
she's like trying to like
make it now and she ended up like
blowing up like that so
it went really fast and what the change
was it was a little like it was at
school people were talking about she was
making videos at school charlie was and
i was like i feel like you shouldn't be
doing that do that anymore
we would call uh text her at school
because she would make them like before
school her and her friends and they had
their their beautiful uniforms on yeah i
want to like people say
take it down right yeah right you're
doing that
and then the school call and they're
like you know she probably shouldn't be
making those videos oh my gosh
i'm happy like it's good that you were
like aware of that monitoring it because
a lot of people don't realize like this
i mean just the safety alone and even
being like
somewhat famous on insta like online
there's so many people that can still
harass and all that stuff and like they
would definitely do that they would do
it like in the bathroom but like
everybody was doing it right then we
went to eat at this pizza place that we
love in new haven and
we were sitting there and charlie was on
this side of me but we were by the
window and this family walks by and this
little girl is like
oh i was like oh my god what are they
looking she's looking at
she's like a pizza and then
i was like we're all kind of like no way
like we're we're 45 minutes from our
house no way this kid knows who she is
right and then when we went outside she
was like hi i love your tick-tock
what the heck so that was pretty crazy
that's a cool moment though it is a cool
moment it went viral like on the college
scene for some reason and
i feel like that one was the one big one
that like
when they would go places people would
because we were coming to l.a a lot yeah
it was like in the airport and it
started out with like little kids and
then they
as time went on they're like they're a
college kid right right up to us so it
aged really fast like no i mean of who
was on the app
i feel like from a viewer's point of
view
the growth of both of your daughter's
platforms was so fast and that's what's
so weird about tick tock is you can grow
so quickly i think more than any other
platform
at what point did you guys say we should
just move to los angeles and take this
on we were going back and forth so much
and
living
out of a suitcase in a hotel was not
ideal
that is the worst it was it was like we
were going to a ton of meetings like
lots of people wanted to meet with them
and we just did everything as family
and
i love that then
we
it what happened was the
we were here and then
the pandemic and
they were talking about like shutting
things down everything down yeah i feel
like we gotta get out of here so we flew
home
and then
that was it everyone was in lockdown and
then
they had already these
signed contracts through these three big
campaigns
that were to be shot here yeah and i'm
like we're not traveling like we're not
going to do that right in a pandemic so
like how are we going to do this
and so they the um the companies like
put together and they got us a private
plan and we moved we rented a house
online that was like we hadn't seen but
it was furnished so we each came with a
suitcase and the dogs
so you were able to
pack up everything and just trust it and
go well yeah so we we pretty much
literally just the suitcase for each of
us like whatever we could bring on my
god backpack suitcase and then um
we came here and they did the campaigns
we shot it at our house yeah i'm like
well one of one or two of them and then
another one was in a studio but there
was like skeleton crew there was hardly
anybody there right yeah really strange
when you guys cause they had deadlines
yeah
our family is super impulsive so
whenever we think of an idea
we move no questions asked i would love
to know the conversation
that you had as a family uh
approaching it
like what was that like because was
there any hazardous emotion
mark is in sales he's in the clothing
business and he's in sales and his he
has a showroom in new york city but
because of the pandemic
he closed it down and his elise was up
he's like i don't know what's happening
i'm not gonna sign my lease again so he
didn't have that
and he has a sales team so
that could work the the north the east
coast yeah and so but he literally he
could do his job anywhere so yeah it
wasn't that big of a deal but
you know of course it was like are we
sure yeah are you sure it's like the
friendships and the family and all that
stuff you've had growing yeah for a
while at home and now you're like up and
going was did you like see any loss of
friendships from like leaving was there
like a transition like that or do you
think it's been pretty well i think
because of the pandemic mm-hmm no one
really saw anybody no
that's true so no one it's not like
we're here and her friends are all
hanging out
that's actually yeah no one was doing
anything probably for charlie the
biggest thing was her dance studio
and those friends and then she has like
a handful of friends from school right
so that was rough but you know how it is
like facetime and everything it makes it
easier yeah i mean especially today if
you're going to see anybody across this
yeah country yeah you can do it two
seconds what i've learned
that they didn't tell us at the time
they were you know mom dad we're just
like gonna really miss opportunities i
feel like we need to move there this is
charlie
and you know so they they're like
scheming behind the scenes because he's
like stop she's still standing i find
these i found these listings of homes
they're fernando dixie found the whole
yeah she was like what's the budget i'll
find this one so she was like
he was worried that they would regret it
that they would miss
school i'm like okay we don't know
what's happening with school everybody's
online at this point they're charlie's
online dixie is a senior she was like
already in college yeah glad you had
gotten into college so it was a little
different for her and like literally
everyone is online yeah and she
um she had been wanting to do online
school to pursue dance yeah for a long
time and so it didn't seem so crazy yeah
and her home studio was very supportive
of her she would train in new york city
and there okay so um she was very lucky
but
so they they're coming in and they're
like serious like you know for this is
just like we want to pursue this right
an opportunity
and now they're like oh we were we were
behind the scenes they're like we wanted
this right you cry today and i'll cry
tomorrow like oh my god sisters are
stuck we're little mischievous sisters
are
i got this so dixie was going to go to
university at alabama she was a senior
she was awesome so when charlie uh was
going to graduate we wanted to live
somewhere warmer i was like right the
winters
we've been safe i was born in miami my
parents lived in florida for a bunch and
then we moved to l.a now they're back in
florida and we're like i don't know if
we can do snow ever oh like i i didn't
grow up with snow
i have people lived in new york though
how did you do that it was hard i didn't
know how to dress and layer mark would
literally like okay we're going shopping
you know mark i love mom
he would shop without me
like do i have to go he's like all right
i'll bring you some stuff but he's oh my
god
she would look like a mobster's wife
yeah it would be a tony
[Applause]
soprano my mom would make him look
perfect my dad would make her look
heinous
[Music]
okay you guys our next sponsor of the
show is
athletic greens it's a product that
sophie and i started using because we
wanted to have more energy we wanted to
go for something that wasn't too
unhealthy tasting it has more of a mild
tropical taste and something i actually
look forward to now in the morning so
you're probably asking what the heck is
this stuff well with one delicious scoop
of athletic greens you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins minerals whole
food source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus aging it goes on and on
what doesn't it do athletic greens is a
lifestyle friendly whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten
gluten-free if you care about me and you
like to look at the ingredient list just
letting you know it only has one gram of
sugar no gmos no nasty chemicals or
artificial flavoring while all still
tasting actually pretty good it supports
better sleep which we all definitely
need help with and recovery and also
supports mental clarity and alertness
look multivitamins are so important for
anyone to take tons of people take some
kind of multivitamin and it's important
to choose one with high quality
ingredients that your body will actually
absorb like athletic grains it's also
such a great company because it's
focused on sustainability they are a
climate neutral certified company in
2020 they purchased carbon credits that
support projects protecting old growth
of rainforests additionally for every
purchase they donate to organizations
helping to get nutritious food to kids
in need including no kid hungry here in
the u.s in 2020 athletic greens donated
over 1.2 million meals to kids you guys
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
the convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into times like flu
season and cold season it's just one
scoop and a cup of water every day and
that's it there's no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
unwaxed again that is athleticgreens.com
unwax to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
[Music]
you guys moved to la you commit yes did
you have any idea
the ride you were about to go on i mean
i don't think anybody could anticipate
that yeah
but again it was the pandemic so
although it was
like
this is what made it weird on
we could see the numbers on social media
on our phones on the computer we could
see that but we didn't feel it because
no one was going anywhere that's true so
that was that's so much actually i think
that's such a weird thing it's so weird
i can't even explain that because you
can there's you can't go to restaurants
so no one can go like oh hey you guys
that's right
but then you're also seeing like the
sponsors the rising numbers like the the
comments the review and so to a lot of
people it didn't make sense like why are
these girls so they're not seeing them
but anywhere but like on social media
yeah yeah
where are they
but meanwhile the
the companies that want to work with
them are totally getting it yeah
at first like nobody wanted to touch
tick tock they're like because you
couldn't monetize
at the beginning well no one knew how to
monetize it or like what if it would
even work because i mean you could see
like even vine like that goes off and
like like how long is this going to be
as fast as it was it was also slow which
i think was a little bit of a good thing
because it gave them time to kind of
process because prior to the pandemic we
were everywhere we were like a super
bowl an nba all-star week and this and
that yeah yeah
charlie and i went to the prada show
like it was yeah you you couldn't even
keep up with how many things
it was just crazy and so
we all got to kind of like let it soak
in in this time yeah and which was kind
of a nice transition when you think of
teenagers moving to l.a like that's
terrifying she loved it she was like
this is my time to trap you in a house
yeah we get to force stay together yeah
so with all this rising fame that it's
like obviously it's all online but then
obvio we knew there was gonna be an
expiration date to this whole uh on
lockdown thing was there something
because you guys you're so grounded and
i i'm assuming your daughters are
definitely as well they seem like it
online and your husband sounds amazing
so was there anything you guys did and
said to each other while this is all
happening to keep yourselves going okay
we are not going to change the way we
are like act up or be something we're
not you know what i'm saying like we're
going to stay true to ourselves we're
not going to think we're better than any
because i think sometimes when people
rise to fame they can kind of get lost
they get lost yeah their head like was
there something you guys said to each
other that said okay
this is who we are like if it were just
dixie or just charlie i think it would
have felt different like it would have
been harder to relate like although it
was obviously the girls but yeah were
kind of in it as well
so we really all understand
and but at the same time that's never
been a conversation but what has
happened is
let's say we're doing
whatever the yeah
thing is at the time for whatever
company
um and they'll come with a script
and maybe if it was just one
that you might yeah oh oh yeah i guess i
could do that but the four of us are
like
you're not saying that this is so dumb
have you guys always been upspoken about
how you want to present yourself because
i know there's been many moments in the
beginning with sophia and i that people
told us to say this or told us to wear
that and we didn't want to say no
because we were just grateful for the
opportunity and we look back and say
that is so unauthentic to who we are
have you guys always been
people to say this is not it we're not
going to do it or did it kind of take
some practice there was definitely never
a question when when something wasn't a
good fit you know or you know the
manager or the agent would come in and
like oh this and yeah this is like great
money and blah blah blah right they're
like yeah i don't eat peanut butter like
i'm not doing that right yeah like but
even that alone like just saying that
yeah so they've been good and charlie
for her being so young yeah really she
has
she's grown a lot but in the beginning
when it was something like that like she
couldn't even articulate
why she didn't want to do it sometimes
but she was like
i can't like i i don't i i can't do that
i feel like
okay
well she has good intuition though she
really did and she her intuition was
ahead of her being able to like explain
why she didn't want to do it like yeah
now she's much better and like has
settled into like she knows like exactly
you know and she also knows both of them
they really know their audience right
you know if somebody wants them to like
do something like our audience isn't
going to buy that they're going to be
like whatever well they started on
tick tock being who they are and that's
why people followed them like that's the
reason why everyone fell in love with
your daughters was because even your
whole family is because of who you are
naturally so it's like it's easy to go
okay this is not my brand like i'm not
gonna promote like a school shirt when
i'm like all about flowers so yeah it's
like it doesn't make sense and it
wouldn't work for the audience yeah for
sure so i would love to transition and
talk about your tv show on hulu oh my
gosh
i watched it when it first came out and
i was really fascinated because
people always have a perception of who
you are who your family is but it really
highlighted behind the scenes and i
didn't realize how much work goes into
day-to-day scheduling
the stress the tears the anxiety the
hard
times that come with being on tick-tock
which you wouldn't assume like a general
person wouldn't assume that
and
i guess my first question would be as a
mom
going through this raising two daughters
that have maybe over what 200 million
combined followers
there were moments where especially
dixie was very vulnerable and she would
cry and break down and it broke my heart
but for you it's like you want to be
there and comfort her but how do you
know what the right advice to give your
daughter is because it's not like
there's a handbook for moms that have
like
wildly famous daughters and they know
exactly how to talk to them in these
times so what do you say to them when
they're you know dealing with online
hate and bullying and just feel like
they can't control themselves or their
emotions mark and i
realized that it didn't matter what the
context was of why they were feeling
whatever they were feeling because
if they were in high school they would
still have that it would be maybe for a
different reason
and so and they're still it's that age
and the way you process things and
all of that so there was never a moment
where we're like oh we're gonna parent
differently we're definitely more
um
compassionate to
when they're getting crushed online for
something
maybe they didn't deserve right um or
something that they did or said that
they didn't really think through right
and so they're getting backlash for it
you know
yeah i agree like you probably shouldn't
have said that you should have thought
before you did that or whatever
but they're getting it so badly that the
last thing that they need is their mom
and dad on top of it like they don't
like to disappoint you know they don't
like to upset anyone mark and i are the
public or anybody so i think just
keeping
uh just kind of being more of an ear
they don't yeah they don't and they've
and dixie not as she's gotten older she
was like i don't always want you to fix
it like i just wanna totally get that
because i know i have anxiety and
sometimes i like i can't even imagine
like i read every comment like i always
am so if someone's like making something
mean about it i it hurts me really
really bad and sometimes all you just
need is someone to be a sounding board
like i don't need someone to tell me how
i'm feeling or how to feel better it's
just let me just talk it out and that
will just make me feel better at the end
of the day because i mean you can't
control what people do online and so the
only thing you control is yourself so if
you need that outlet to just like lash
out and like i like sometimes i'll just
cry and cry and then also be like okay
office every single day well this is
what we're kind of seeing and we had
heard this like it takes five years for
you to like not get so emotional over
all the comments oh it does and that's
what i've heard that's actually so many
years do i have left
well it's very easy for us to look at a
timeline because we know like when it
started i like a timeline i'm like okay
in five years
but they've definitely like now it
doesn't bother them as much i think too
because we were in the pandemic and all
of that
now
they're going out they're actually
seeing people that do love them
appreciate that they're putting
themselves out there and or they can
relate to feeling those anxious feelings
and they're like oh wait those people
are out there like it feels like it's
just hate when you're yeah you know
you're not meeting people and we always
say this we said the worst part about
tick tock is that people are so creative
on how to be so mean and witty on the
app and that gets the most likes it's at
the top okay that's awesome but also to
transition back to um the hulu reality
show was that something that you guys
were
offered or was that something you guys
were like actually something we've
always wanted to do and the offer came
you're like wait this is perfect and
this is great timing like was that even
a consideration before people were
coming to us early on about a reality
show but
we were
not
like
first of all we're like i don't know if
i'm just going to want to watch like
i don't like my reality but but i love
that what we first thought was
we didn't want it to be like traditional
reality yeah we wanted it to be more of
a documentary because like if people
think they know who we are just from
what they see online like let's tell the
true story right this is what's
happening in our life and it was a you
know i mean when we went back and
watched it it was tough it was a hard
time but also like a lot of people were
struggling after being in lockdown for
so long and all of that
i don't i think it was just a sign of
the times like now that things are
opening up and they're traveling and and
meeting people
it's
they've like they're settling into yeah
wait this is my life and there are
people that do like what i'm doing and
and it's like feels better now yeah and
so they've come a long way so
well yeah that's also cool for you
because um now moms get to watch like
the other side of it like how you're
able to manage and i mean like you're
the mother of the household you have the
raised girls are in this like incredibly
complicated industry under a lot of
pressure like and i mean has your life
changed since then too with like the way
that moms are responding to you or the
way that you like the brands you want to
work with and all this stuff is it how's
your life changed since then yeah i love
when moms
like i don't get a lot of people coming
up to me but when sometimes it'll be
moms and they're like i loved your show
and you know and i think i've even we've
said in the show just
if they had a hundred followers and they
got some mean comments like it feels the
same feels the same so i think every
parent can relate to that and you know
with your kids on social media and that
kind of thing so
kind of got some perspective i think
from
other moms watching right yeah
but um that has been super
awesome and then there i've had a lot of
oh i'm not gonna get emotional but a lot
of girls that
oh my god they're gonna make you kind of
stuff that are like you know i was at
dixie's concert jingle ball and i'm like
the girl in front of me there was a
bunch of like teenage girls and
she turned around and she was just
crying and she was like can i hug you
and i was like of course she was like i
don't have a relationship with my mom
and i always look at you and how you are
your kids all the time oh my god we are
crying
i'm just like a mess
stuff like that it is
like
that you know i don't know i had a great
family life and you know the girls and i
are close so but there are people out
there that don't have that i mean i know
i get i there's like a handful of girls
that have reached out online yeah
um you know supporting them or whatever
i don't know who they are it's so
different to see it and what's here and
she was like can i hug yeah she just
hugged me so tight and i was like you're
like i could be your mom too
it's true and it's it's so refreshing to
see a family that's close and and that's
what i loved about the show is because
you guys were such a tight unit and
every decision went through everyone and
you guys all valued each other's
opinions and i really liked seeing dixie
and charlie their relationship because
you know it could be
people could think oh they're just doing
it for tick tock but they're really like
close girls and i think that's awesome
because that's how i look at sophia and
my polar opposites too like we we fight
like dogs like this morning we did but
it's like do they do they
help each other out as well through
these times
when it gets really hard they're both
really really funny so charlie could be
like
devastated about like oh my god my face
is broken out whatever and charlie and
dixie will come in with some joke that's
like
not the time dixie and then charlie's
like oh my god you're so funny or the
next time she'll be like why are you so
mean to me so she's like never know
what's gonna happen
but um when push comes to shove they
have each other's backs so hardcore yeah
it's so
great but like they argue
i think they wait until they're in front
of us to argue
really can you guys just get along and
so wait is it fine is it because because
sophie and i do this sometimes we'll
bring it up in front of our parents so
that whoever's parent agrees with this
child is the winner who's the winner and
if they do that
together
like okay tell us like which one makes
the most most sense in this she thinks
this and i think i'm like i'm not doing
this i know our mom is getting less in
it now and now it makes us even more mad
so then we just keep until one of us she
doesn't answer our face time we're like
well i guess we tied yeah
so is there anything on the show that
because you guys exposed so much of your
life i mean you really put it all out
there but is there something on the show
that you guys are like you know what
this is gonna stay just with the family
we'd like to keep some part of us locked
away just for us i mean we were or even
just like something that just wasn't
interesting yeah like more of that like
so it's pretty much like the way it is
like the emotions were were that was
what was the time yeah
so
you know like you film for all these
months and they get this much footage
yes there was a lot of times in there we
were having a good time too yeah you're
like there wasn't always
it was uh highlighted
more sad times than good times
i think so yeah
because i think
uh the girls we're all executive
producers on it and it was very
important for the girls that's really
important to
show that
you know the effects of that you know
they were kind of hoping people who
write these awful things online so it
was happening would see it and i will
tell you there was definitely has been a
shift really yeah and there's been like
tea pages that like change the way they
do things it was interesting wow
even like paparazzi is different now
it's been very interesting so they're
like you know i just people just need to
see the reality of it and the effects of
it yeah because i remember when that
came when that came out that
like certain segments of your show where
it talked about like the really bad
bullying and the fact on tick tock
people were like oh my god i had no idea
like look how like effective she is by
this and i think people really thought
twice before you can be so brave behind
a computer screen but when you see the
effects firsthand i mean that's hard to
still say to someone's face so is there
a season two we're filming now oh my god
are you really we are what should we
expect from season two
well i think like everybody
that is now getting to live their life a
little bit more like everything's a
little bit lighter yeah a little more
fun
like this season no tears but i mean i
think you'll see
you know the things that the girls are
working on and dixie with music and
charlie not sure what she wants to do
you know she's going to be 18 soon and
what does that mean and that's crazy she
doesn't drive but she must move out and
i don't know so oh my god yeah so lots
of growing pains yeah it's almost like a
normal teenage stuff but just
elevated and i feel like just i mean i
don't know how it'll come across on the
show just in our life now like to see
the girls sort of
like okay this is my life right i'm
happy they're settling like they're
settling in and that's like all like i
know it does not perfect right they have
their moments what is that like getting
to life no no i really commend you guys
because
every family goes through their stuff
every daughter has their day
and to have a camera on you while it's
happening with millions of people's
opinions is not easy and you guys handle
it gracefully and i think that is really
amazing i'm excited to see season two
yeah we really love season one we've
talked thank you sort of to wrap it up
we've talked a lot about how it's been
really hard with the comments and things
that you have to let go of and move on
from but what has been the best part
about this whole new transition like
what has been the best thing that has
happened from
the start of her posting this first
video
and your life today i know this is gonna
sound cliche but like as a mom whether
they were in school or
like to see your kids happy that's all
we want like
try to see them not letting the hate get
to him as much to see them doing things
in spite of
what the people might oh you don't
deserve to do that like you know what i
don't care because this is what i want
to do and every single person on this
planet has a right to go after like
something that makes him happy or try to
figure out what that is so
i don't know like i don't know i'm
probably meeting j.lo
she is a boss but oh my gosh i have to
be like that but you're not a regular
mom you're a cool you're honestly the
coolest mom look at her cool prada shoes
i always look at you for fit i'm like
you are you really awesome and i was so
excited to talk to you and you
completely blew our expectations yeah i
mean we already had high expectations we
know how nice you were on the show and
we're like okay you're so much cooler
and nicer and you're such an amazing mom
and you've done an incredible job and
i'm so thank you
my youtube channel thank you yes i know
i'm so excited about myself so where can
people find your youtube channel your
socials
hiding emilio pretty much on everything
but i've been consistently posting i
just started my youtube channel and i'm
excited
and then dixie was like is it just going
to be decor on your
phone
by the way i'm like dressing up
new apartments so i will be all over
well i'm going to no but she she does
that and i'm like do i need to change it
and i'm like you know what she's right
like mix it up so they do they do want
to help me and like i like that
so my youtube channel that's good and
then our podcast mark and i will be
coming back oh good soon oh i'm
listening to that so that'll be fun
thank you so much you have such a
beautiful heart we love you so much and
i love you guys and your family
well thank you guys so much for watching
this week's episode and we will see you
next tuesday bye
[Music]
you